si les blessés
ça y est ça varie au quai de l'adour
j'suis snob l'inconnu toit vient en
voiture bar oui il était comment
c'est lui qui a fait le premier article
avant c'est ce que j'ai fait non j'ai
pris une gomme pour effacer mais
tellement j'étais il ya 10 bande de cons
acheté dix premiers 10 de ce saint divy
du lycée peu galvaudé pas encore gagnent
leur imam j'étais chez lui m'a dit vous
savez ce que quel est votre technique
vous avez la même technique que call
center pour les rejets parti je ne vais
pas redire
[Musique]
sega a les garçons bouchers
ça fait un clip avec eux je vois plus la
même mais n'était même pas à mi avion il
nous propose ici parce que je les aimais
bien je suis invité gilles était bien
plus qu'une production qui connaissent à
toi il connaît pas au suivant un partout
[Musique]
elle a eu la petite marianne un
chevalier du ciel de deux des quatre
[Musique]
histoires ouais tu ris quand je suis de
bonne humeur ce matin à celle avec au
delà
si tu vas à dire d'ailleurs
elle laissa le sénat vient moi c'était
un pote à moi
avant il était drôle a été tueur milan
structure et il était était charmant il
était charmant sétif alors continue
cortile score
[Musique]
bailly le stress quatre dossiers qui va
tout va plus la tulle m
il met alors alors alors on est tous à
la paillade
ça va quoi toi marielle ou non un taré
nord merde à celle internet non non non
at a time when des séries non en fait
j'ai un compte ou non
mona il s'en sort bien elle s était le
piège
as-tu tomber dans le piège sérgio à la
mort c'était moreno c'était pas loin ses
mots et la chaussée
alcool adore ça fait tard et alors vous
allez trop vite pour moi c'est
guadalcanal la ceinture de tous les
côtés allez vas-y mon petit la route
fleurie
très bien
[Musique]
voilà ça devient un peu plus dur la
campagne 1
bah oui messieurs adaptation ces petits
hameaux et un mauvais sa sentence et
aymen gilberto potes si le spi avançait
c'est un oui c'est le paroxysme joj je
crois qu
vous savez pas bon il allait encore dans
toi tu les a payés pour qu'ils me
battrai encore une fois c'est duval le
parolier de lio je tenais ça serait bien
d'aller dehors il est à 30 ans est
recueillie bouyer mauvais joueur alors
je pense que l'on trouve aussi un geste
de mexx au total data président à 6,1 à
6,6 ici
c'est patrice et marion c'est dur les
projets avec quatre scénarios graal pour
les connaître
matrix et par your way tiko et dario fo
de la chanson gens très très bien
patrice et mario c'est tout mais bravo
est identique à un promu
2il à ja
on
[Applaudissements]
tu sais que la dernière chanson qu'il a
enregistrés dans sa vie non je t'aime
moi non plus sa dernière folie les
vidéos t'aime moi non plus pourquoi
l'oiseau a sorti ses sorties mais ils on
va le mettre dans le prochain blind test
on va devant nous en ville je t'aime moi
non plus sur les poils du chat d'après
brigitte bardot et aux caf la version de
bardos et c'est mary jane ont été numéro
1 en angleterre où le faire
les abeilles dans cette loi c'est beau
la taupe le web wright ça fait de la
peine c'est le nom de bourvil en ses
forces pour bernard oui alors amants à
la promotion des régions c'est parti sur
les mêmes pistes pour laisser passer les
trois du tchad ardisson que la presse
jugeait la plus franche
il ya les poils de chat l'arbitrage je
les foule
sachons j'ai eu c'est un match piège à
wii fit sur wii grand pianiste un groupe
je suis piégé un franc jeu
ouais pourquoi le et qui s'essayait
écoute et à l'auvergne
oui allô mer
je suis comme ça craint
comme c'est un imitateur au début
j'avais pas compris qu'il s'était c'est
l'imitateur imitateurs ouais bon allez
on aventure ils ont gagné alors les
applaudit ouais fois que c'est pas
méconnaître les gilts eu la jambe par
l'orgasme
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus